Joe Biden and Jill Biden have released
their 2022 taxes and even though the
right Wingers are trying to make a
controversy out of them I have to tell
you there is nothing controversial about
the Biden income nor the Biden taxes but
David they made more than half a million
dollars
let's go through it the the bidens did
indeed make
579 thousand dollars last year as a
household and they paid a 23.8 percent
federal tax rate plus of course state
tax as well now there are people seeing
this and saying oh my goodness this is
just like Trump
super wealthy
multi-millionaires no guys no without
passing any value judgment over income
it's very important to understand that
Trump made like 400 million dollars a
year during his presidency above was
about 1.6 billion throughout the the
entire presidency if I recall correctly
um and is a multi-billionaire at least
as far as We Know Joe Biden is a
multi-millionaire that's true so is
Bernie Sanders I've explained before if
you've been making six figures for 30
years you should be a multi-millionaire
by the time you're 80. even if you save
only a modest amount of your income and
put it in low-cost index funds and wait
for 30 years if you're not a
multi-millionaire you've messed up
you're really bad with money that's not
controversial
now 579 000 combined income presidents
make 400 Grand a year is it 400 or 440
is it's a it's around 400 000 a year
that's the presidential salary that's
the vast majority of their income Jill
Biden also made uh what was it here
about eighty thousand dollars uh
teaching and they ended up yeah eighty
two thousand dollars teaching at
Northern Virginia Community College
totally standard uncontroversial salary
so that gets us to 482 thousand dollars
and then there was a little bit of
income I don't remember
um what it was for
um they made some donations uh to some
Charities and blah blah blah blah blah
so what is the right saying about this
the best they have is Joe Biden is using
an S corporation for his book profits
this is the best they have and in fact
there's a Fox News article
um they've they've gone at this before
this is a couple years old
multi-millionaire Biden's use of s
corporations draws scrutiny by
Republican who sees hypocrisy I even got
emails from some in my audience who said
that there are people on the left
criticizing Biden for using an S
corporation for his book I listen guys
I'm calling this stuff like it is there
is nothing controversial about Joe Biden
Biden running his book profits through
an S corporation I got emails about this
being shady
and just like Donald Trump give me a
break okay only if you know nothing
about taxes could you come to the
conclusion that simply having an S
corporation is in any way sketchy first
of all
authors don't set up
a C Corp
for a book you just don't do it if they
did then you have to pay yourself via
salary and dividends it just doesn't
make any sense if you're a small
business like the author of a book and
you want to separate those
um uh revenues from just yourself as an
individual sole proprietorship the S
corporation or a partnership might might
make perfect sense there's nothing
illegal there's nothing Shady it's a
standard practice it's pass-through
income it goes on your personal tax
return it's not evasive it's not a
loophole it's a completely standard way
that small businesses that don't want to
just be sole proprietorships would set
up Revenue in this case you get some
liability protection you also I mean
listen if you have a full-time job in
the case of Joe Biden Senator vice
president president it's very logical
that if you have a defined and distinct
project like a book
that you would separate that and not run
it as a sole proprietorship through your
social security number you would get an
EIN and set it up as an S corporation it
lets you pay yourself a reasonable
salary take the remainder as
distributions you can potentially reduce
your tax liability slightly because it
can potentially reduce self-employment
taxes but Joe Biden's maxing out on that
anyway because he makes 400 Grand a year
and the cap is in the mid 150s this is
like milk toast milk toast stuff and
whether you're on the left or the right
and you're saying Biden's just like
Trump because his book profits run
through an S corporation you're either
arguing in bad faith or you just don't
understand even the basics about small
business taxes so I I don't think we
need to entertain it any further
579k in income when you're the president
and your wife works that makes a lot of
sense paid we can say well the tax at
that level of income should be higher
fine but an effective tax rate federally
of 24 and then paying Delaware attacks
totally reasonable totally expected I
think that's a higher tax rate than
Warren Buffett pays by the way even
though the Biden's made a lot less
there's nothing controversial here Biden
paid his taxes he released his tax
returns if we could only say the same
thing for Donald Trump